estas elecciones podrían cambiar el
futuro de irlanda del norte por primera
vez desde su creación hace un siglo el
sinn fein podría salir victorioso el
partido nacionalista a favor de la
reunificación está dirigido por michel o
neill únase a nosotros en el camino
hacia la unidad de irlanda un camino
pacífico y democrático desde hace
semanas todos los sondeos pronostican la
victoria del sinn fein sobre el partido
unionista democrático en el centro del
debate está la cuestión del referendo
sobre la reunificación de irlanda no he
fijado una fecha pero si quiero que
suceda
llevará a la inestabilidad del irlanda
del norte no resolverá los problemas que
importan a la gente de a pie este debate
se ha reavivado con el break sheet
defendido por el gobierno británico y
apoyado por el partido unionista en el
poder pero rechazado por el 56% del
territorio un protocolo especial
estableció una frontera aduanera entre
irlanda del norte y el reino unido- y
controles que fueron muy criticados por
la población
ahora hay mucho papeleo que antes no
había solo había que llamar a la empresa
hacer el pedido y lo tendrían en unos
días ahora lleva mucho tiempo
una posible victoria del sinn fein
podría haber parecido inverosímil no
hace mucho tiempo ya que se le ha
asociado históricamente con el grupo
paramilitar irá el ejército republicano
de irlanda su ventaja en las encuestas
radica en que sus candidatos se han
centrado en cuestiones sociales como el
coste de vida y no en la reunificación
de irlanda una cuestión que sólo el 30
por ciento de los norirlandeses apoyaría
según una reciente encuesta de la
universidad de liverpool